it's another Florida man this morning
who made an amazing discovery along
Florida's a Treasure Coast and that
Coast lived up to its name last month
two treasure hunters Florida men using
metal detectors discovered 22 Spanish
coins on a beach believed to be from a
shipwreck more than 300 years old coins
estimated to be worth about six thousand
dollars and all best part is they're
gonna be able to keep these coins on
like what coins that if they found them
in the ocean you need a special permit
for that it or not sometimes the country
of Spain will sue to get it back but
because they found it on a public beach
they get to keep their fine 300 years
yeah I know there are only worth six
thousand dollars I would think they well
it's still were they didn't find the
gold okay there's a lot more out there
apparently there were 11 ships galleons
monkey in a hurricane in 1715 Wow I'd be
going back to that beach like every day
yeah I know
Florida man story and it's a good
Florida man story